ah yes David and I watched uh NCIS
um
two nights three nights in a row have
you ever seen NCIS man and I don't mean
the original one I don't know the one
with Mark Harmon really but I'm talking
about the New Orleans one
with Lucas whatever the [ __ ] guy's name
is from uh Friday Night Lights and Scott
Bakula Scott Bakula was in Quantum Leap
okay
and he he is a cool looking dude
whatever
now in NCIS there were three times I was
watching an episode of nine of NCIS and
I actually had the thought
wait that is Scott Bakula right
because he kind of looks like a guy that
looks like Scott Bakula now
and that's what happens when you get
older a little bit and that's fine but
he did Quantum Leap that's what he was
really famous for and then all of a
sudden he's on and say dude imagine
being a guy that was had a a real career
in the in the early 90s
and now it's 2 000 and I think 15 or 14
is when it started NCIS and they and
they call you 30 years later and they're
like hey Scott Bakula want to be in the
new NCIS you gotta feel like Scott
Bakula must have just been like
uh
oh I'm the luckiest guy in the world
like how could you
not work for 30 years and then all of a
sudden just be given a franchise I mean
I know he worked and [ __ ] and I'm
obviously but like this NCIS dude they
make NCIS out of any City and it becomes
a [ __ ] Smash Hit from jump dude
NCIS
NCIS Los Angeles which by the way is
still on that started in like 2007. NCIS
is still on that started in 2003 that
it's been on for 20 years Mark Harmon
last year was like you know what I think
I'm gonna actually not do it I'll let
the show run without me dude for after
19 years Mark Harmon where 400 million
dollars dude and now he's a producer on
all of them how the [ __ ] does that work
dude they're just handing money out you
know
so now I'm watching Nola NCIS Nola and
Scott Bakula dude is in it and the other
Lucas guy is in it and then two like
kind of maybe Hispanic women of course
they were like are they Hispanic and
then another dude that's a guitar lanky
white dude that looks like Neil Brennan
stretched out and then another dude
that's like a black dude in a wheelchair
and um just like a yup dude
is didn't say I stand for not come on
insane [ __ ] dude this is so regular this
show the guy's name is
Dwayne
Scott backless name is Dwayne Pride dude
and they call him
King
the most badass [ __ ] my name is Dwayne
Pride yeah but call me King so badass
dude
my name is nut hugger chick fugger but
call me scrotum that's the only more
badass [ __ ]
laughs
scrotum tonight at 11.
scrotum on after Magnum PI tonight at
11.
uh an all-new scrotum
[Applause]
we're gonna have to stretch this case
out
and then instead of the sunglasses just
pulling his scrotum
looks like looks like this chick just
such bad [ __ ] taglines looks like
this chick hey you know what
yeah I understand that we're at odds and
normally I would take this case but this
time balls are in your court
[Applause]
just take stretches and scrolled and
puts it over his head and flies away
on an all new scrotum
previously on scrotum laughs
[Applause]
oh no look at this he kneels down here
hold my nuts hold my nuts I gotta kneel
down and get a closer look
previously on scrotum hold my nuts I
gotta get a closer look oh no this
killer is absolutely crazy it looks like
the balls are in his court
[Applause]
um
I don't know here comes scrotum God damn
it
oh here he comes uh Hey scrotum how's it
going looking particularly veiny today
um so
oh no this person died in vain
[Applause]
dude so dumb
oh no this person it looks like my oh no
my cock's about to spit up
what that one didn't even make sense
[Music]
[Music]